FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 93 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am good.
I'm in Seattle, so we're
doing the remote thing today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay.
And I had all of the
issues possible to have
trying to set up the Mac today
because I'm learning still.
It's only 93 episodes
in, our first time.
Anyway, we have today
a very special episode.
I'm actually very
excited because we
have one of the developer
advocates from our team
that we had not had
before in the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We have Melanie Warrick
joining us today.
She's going to talk to
us about what is AI?
What does that mean?
What does that relate
to machine learning?
Is it just a brand new thing?
Is it something just different?
Who knows?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I really like it because
this episode came up
after basically
having lunch, and we
were talking about machine
learning and AI and everything.
And she was like, well,
AI and machine learning
are very different things.
And we're like, really?
And she had that opinions--
MARK MANDEL: Yes, tell us more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
she has opinions of this.
So we decided to make an
episode out of her opinions.
And they're really
interesting, so I'm
very excited about
the whole episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
And then after that, we
have our usual question
of the week where we talk about,
say you want to do something
whenever any pod within
your Kubernetes cluster
is either created or destroyed.
How do you do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
I have some ideas.
But before we go to
that and before we
go with the main content, we
have as always our cool things
of the week.
And we have four of them today.
So I'm going to let you start.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So the first one here is
around Stackdriver Logging.
It went GA a little
while ago, but we've
been basically talking to
a bunch of the people who
use this product.
And we want to give them
some new features that
are super cool.
So there's a bunch of stuff.
We'll link to the full articles.
Actually, there's a couple
that come out of the blog post.
But you can do neat stuff like
being able to pull metrics out
of logging now.
So if you're tracking
response times
or any other types of
metrics, you can pull that in.
We've made it faster to make log
entries available within there.
You can manage logs
across organizations.
So not only just managing
logs within a project,
you can do log
aggregation exports
across wide varieties of
projects all together.
And you can also do this really
cool thing which I quite like--
and we'll link to a
longer article about it--
which is now called exclusion
filters, which is say,
for example, you might
have debug statements
that you have that are spitting
out from your applications,
but most of the time you
actually don't care about them.
So you can say,
hey, I don't really
care about these
with Stackdriver,
so that means it's
not going to count
towards the gigabytes
or the storage costs
that you would necessarily
have there within your project.
Which is probably good to know,
because Stackdriver Logging now
offers 50 gigabytes of logs
per project per month for free.
That will be starting
in December 1.
I think most people will
probably not hit that 50
gigabytes, but some will.
So be aware that that is coming.
But yeah, so up to 50 gigabytes.
But yeah, you can use exclusion
filters, pull that down.
Maybe if you're getting
like health checks,
you're like, hmm, don't care
about those, 200 requests,
stuff like that.
There's a longer
conversation about that.
One of our other
teammates, Aja Hammerly,
who wrote a whole
article about preventing
log waste with
Stackdriver Logging
that we'll also link to as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
50 gigabytes sounds
like a lot, but I
guess that some more customers
might be somewhere around
there--
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --even higher.
So good to know.
The second cool thing of
the week is a new article.
It's actually the
third part of a trilogy
on how to build conversational
applications using
Cloud Machine Learning APIs.
And it is really cool,
partly because I'm actually
preparing a talk for Sydney.
I will be talking
exactly about this topic.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So it's very good
to see that there's
a new article on it.
And basically, it's
about how do you
describe intents for Google--
not Google Home.
The example is with Google
Home, but you can actually
do with whatever you want to do.
Actions with Google
Home, but you
can also do things like
Facebook Messenger or Slack.
And all of these things
work through API.AI.
And it is very cool because it
is actually incredibly simple
to use.
You basically say,
OK, if someone says,
I'd like to buy
some milk, then you
know that you're
going to relate that
to a use case, which is
the buy, buy something,
and the product is milk.
And then you can
make it to be like,
oh, well, we don't
know the quantity,
so let's ask the quantity.
So you can actually create
this two-ways conversation
that then you can
use from any device.
So you write it only once.
You're write you're
backend on the other side.
And then people will be able
to access your smart service
from, as I was saying, Facebook
Messenger, Slack, Google Home,
but also like Skype and
LINE and way more services.
It's pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: That is cool.
Well, I can't wait to
see your talk, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I can't
wait to see it either.
Especially, I can't wait to
be done with it, especially
the slides.
But soon I'll be
working on that.
If the organizer of the Cloud
Summit Sydney is listening,
my slides are done.
Yes, they're totally finished.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: So we've
also got this book that
has recently been released.
I'm going to mess up all these
names, but I'll try my best.
So Tyler Akidau, Slava
Chernyak, and Reuven Lax,
they're co-authors of an
upcoming coming O'Reilly book
called, "Streaming Systems--
The What, Where, When, and
How of Large-Scale Data
Processing."
Say that three times quickly.
It's now in early release.
Basically, it is intended
to be the canonical resource
for streaming big data and
managing it and analyzing
it and processing it at
scale with really big scale,
Google scale, for
people who want
to be doing that as
well in the companies
that they are involved in.
It looks like it's going
to be a really cool book.
We're going to have a link here
basically to a little interview
that was done with some
of the authors there,
telling about why
they wrote the book,
what sort of stuff people can
look at, what do they really
even mean by streaming--
what does that mean--
and sort of barriers
to adoption,
and why did they write this
thing in the first place.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
going to ask you a question.
What do you think is my
favorite part of this book?
MARK MANDEL: That it's
all written in Java?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, no, no.
No, the fact that
they're talking
about streaming and on
the cover of the book
there's a fish because a river.
MARK MANDEL: Fishes, streams.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
easy, easy humor.
If you're really
interested in it,
you can access a thing with
the free trial on O'Reilly,
and also it's available on
Amazon if you want to read it.
Very cool book.
And we're going to have our last
cool thing of the week, which
is something that, in my
opinion, is super cool.
I don't know if you've ever
heard about this thing called
Quick, Draw!
with Google.com.
And it's this little app that
you can use on your phone
or on your computer, and
basically you access it
and you draw whatever,
and it guesses what it is.
So it's kind of like Pictionary.
And this is powered by
machine learning, of course,
with neural networks and
convolutional neural networks.
The cool thing is that
convolutional networks
are cool, but they
need a lot of data.
And we just open
sourced that data,
the data that was used to train
that neural network, which
is super useful
because then you can
do whatever you want with that.
You can train how to
do Pictionary again,
but also you can
do more analysis.
Like, according to all of
these drawings of a cat,
what does a cat look like
according to each country?
And you can do an average
and be like, cats in Japan
are actually slightly different
to cats in the United States.
It is really cool.
You can do lots of really
cool data processing.
And also, the data even includes
not only the finished drawing
but also how it was
drawn, so you can actually
follow the traces.
MARK MANDEL: This is amazing.
I'm just playing with
just the Data Explorer,
and I've clicked randomly.
I've clicked on parrot,
and I'm currently
looking at 163,567
parrot drawings made
by real people on the internet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
It is amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You can go through and be like,
nope, that's not a parrot.
This is so cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
MARK MANDEL: I just want
to play with this all day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I told
you that's why that
was a cool thing of the week.
It is super cool.
And if you're into
machine learning,
definitely check it out.
But if you're not
into machine learning,
check it out because it's
actually lots of fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm going to stare at this for
hours if I don't close it now.
Cool.
Well, I tell you what.
Why don't we go have a chat
with our good friend Melanie
and talk all about AI and
ML and all that fun stuff?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
Let's do that.
I am very, very happy today
to welcome one of the latest
additions to the Cloud Developer
Advocacy team, Melanie Warrick.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Doing great, thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I am
very happy because we're
going to be talking about
a very interesting topic
that we were actually
discussing over lunch,
and we decided that
this conversation
would be a great episode.
So we're going to be
talking about AI and stuff.
But before that, why
don't you us a little bit
about yourself, what
did you do at Google,
when did you join,
stuff like that?
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
So I am a senior developer
advocate at Google
and started four months ago.
I know you guys know about that.
But prior to that, I was
working for a startup
on a neural net platform
that was not TensorFlow
and developing that out.
And before that, I was
working at Change.org
implementing machine learning
algorithms into production.
Change.org, for anybody
who doesn't know,
is an online petition platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And somehow,
in one of those conferences,
I think that you met
Mark before that, right?
MELANIE WARRICK: I
did back in the day.
Mark and I met at
Strange Loop actually.
MARK MANDEL: A long,
long, long time ago,
in a land far away, but yes.
I got very excited
when I found out
Melanie was joining the team.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
Me too.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right.
Well, we're here
to talk about AI.
So what is AI?
Is it ML just like a new coat
of paint, or what's the deal?
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
what it feels like lately.
Everything's called AI.
Artificial intelligence
in particular
is, the actual definition is
the science and engineering
of technology or tech in
some way, shape, or form.
And this was initially
coined back in the '50s
to give us a history
lesson, because I
know that's what
everybody wants to hear.
But that's when it
originally was labeled.
And then, over the years,
it's been this process
of seeing if we can
actually achieve
what people expect from it.
But the reality is the
expectations are constantly
kind of changing, and
what people really
want when they say
AI, a lot of people
are really just looking
for human-like artificial
intelligence.
They want to see robots
that are like humans.
It's what we have fun with
all of our sci-fi and fantasy.
When we see it labeled
today, most people
are talking about what's
known as narrow AI,
and so they're
expecting technology
that's really good in a
specific area, that's constantly
learning and adapting.
So that's where that
term is getting used,
and it's replacing a lot of
times ML, or Machine Learning.
Machine learning, in
essence, is the algorithms
that are used in AI, or
some of the algorithms
that are used in AI.
And when I say algorithms,
I mean the math part,
stuff that you use
the computations for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you
mentioned narrow intelligence.
I can imagine like,
for instance, there
was an example that we
talked about as a cool thing
of the week where there
was this farm of cucumbers.
And there was something
that was able to decide
the kind of cucumber
that it was able to see.
That would be narrow, right?
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
So what you're talking
about in that cucumber
example in particular,
that is using
an algorithm that is known as
deep learning or neural nets.
And in particular, that's a type
of machine learning algorithm.
And machine learning
is a set of algorithms
that are used in
artificial intelligence.
But it's not the
only thing you use
for artificial intelligence.
And so for the
cucumber example--
and I'd have to look at it to
really make sure I'm on point
on this-- but basically
the cucumber example
is machine learning for sure.
And if it's continually
adapting and changing
in terms of how
it operates, then
technically it's narrow AI.
Now, some would say,
well, it's definitely
AI based on this current
paradigm we're living in.
But I would say for narrow
AI, it's probably there,
but it just depends
on how much it
continues to change and learn.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And you said something
before that I thought
it was kind of interesting.
You said when people come
to AI, what they often want
is a human-like response.
But when you're talking
about sort of narrow AI,
I'm almost wondering whether
the response you get out
of machines is almost things
that possibly humans couldn't
do?
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
So when I say when
they come to AI
and they want
human-like response,
they want to see a
robot that really can
think and feel and have ideas.
And you have to
say, when you look
at a car that can
drive itself, does it
have an awareness of itself?
Is it conscious?
Can generalize not
just from driving
to actually doing other
things that are out there?
And granted, it's pretty
general to be able to drive.
But in terms of narrow, you
have to think about the fact
that it's able to
specifically be
an expert in a specific
field, and it could be better
than humans in that field.
AlphaGo and DeepMind
had successfully
beat a number of the best
players in that field.
That is a great example of
where you have an algorithm that
has been successfully
trained to exceed
what humans are capable of.
So that's definitely
very possible.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that would be narrow AI.
And for general AI or wide AI--
I don't know how to call it--
other than "Prometheus" and
"Alien" and movies like that,
is there an actual use
case of that kind of AI?
MELANIE WARRICK: Do
we have that now?
As far as everybody knows, no.
I mean, maybe somebody is
hiding something in a back room
somewhere.
But as far as we all know,
all we have right now
is what's termed as narrow AI.
We don't actually
have general AI,
which is what you
usually mean when
you're talking about
anything that's human-like.
And then there's super
AI because you've
got to have the super with
all the various Superman,
super shows that are coming out.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Now I'm excited.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
So this is where you
start to get down to where
they talk about singularity.
And they say this
is having AI that
will go above and beyond what
humans can actually understand.
It's capable of
doing things that
go beyond our comprehension.
And that's where you start to
dive into the real extreme.
The world will come to an
end, or we will live forever.
And there's some
real serious concerns
in this space for
certain people.
It gets used, especially in
the fun, sci-fi fantasy world.
But the realities of
that, it's not really
something that the people
who are really researching
the space are concerned
about, and they
don't see it as being a reality
if ever, if anytime soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We'll come back to those
concerns a little bit later,
but you mentioned something that
I thought was very interesting.
You said that
machine learning is
the algorithms that are used for
AI, but AI is more than machine
learning.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
else do we have in AI
that is not machine learning?
MELANIE WARRICK:
So machine learning
is a field of
research in the space,
and there's a number
of different fields.
You have statistics
and probability models
that get intermixed
with machine learning,
but they are their own thing.
They're not necessarily
machine learning.
You have graph theory.
Some people might even
touch on quantum mechanics
or quantum computing, which
is also a little bit more
of a not fully-concrete
space itself.
But it's fun to
explore and think
about what's the
possibility there
and how it can potentially have
impact in AI at some point.
So there are a number
of different fields
that will come together,
sometimes on their own,
sometimes in concert,
to be able to achieve
this artificial intelligence.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So probably bring
it back to, say,
like Google Cloud or some
of our open source projects,
is TensorFlow AI, or
is it machine learning,
or does it just depend
on how you use the thing?
MELANIE WARRICK: So TensorFlow
primarily gets referenced
and used in relation
to deep learning.
And as I mentioned,
that's where you
start talking about neural nets
and applying neural nets, which
are one of many
algorithms that are
in the machine learning space.
So yes, it can play
a role and be used
and has been used in artificial
intelligence projects.
DeepMind, for example,
currently uses
TensorFlow in some
of their algorithms
when they're doing
anything around gaming.
Not everything, but I know that
it's used in some of the work
that they're doing
and other research
spaces that they're in.
Just because you're
using TensorFlow
doesn't mean you're doing AI.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I mean, the Hello World of
TensorFlow is you do 2 plus 2,
and you run it and it says 4.
That's probably not AI.
MELANIE WARRICK: No, that's not.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MELANIE WARRICK: But yeah,
it's definitely deep learning,
or it can be deep learning,
and primarily that
is machine learning as
the bigger umbrella.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So since you're a
developer advocating--
your main topic is
AI, machine learning.
Could you tell us a little
bit about what kind of things
can you do with AI
or machine learning
on Google Cloud Platform, or
what do people tend to do?
What do you see the most often?
MELANIE WARRICK: So in
terms of machine learning
on Google Cloud Platform,
Google Cloud Platform
it's basically servers.
It's computers at
the end of the day.
So you can do whatever you
want that you currently can
do on Google Cloud Platform.
That's something that I think
is really important to stress,
that it's like any cloud
platform you're going to use.
You can use the tools,
any tools you want.
You just have to configure it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
one of those tools
may be like, for
instance, TensorFlow,
for which we have a
managed version, which
is Cloud ML Engine.
MARK MANDEL: What
is it called now?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
That's my knowledge as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
it's Cloud ML Engine.
But if you were interested
in using something
else other than TensorFlow,
you could also use it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Correct.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Now, the thing is
that I have no idea what
other things are out there
other than TensorFlow.
So I don't know.
Is there's some other
very well-known library,
some competitor of TensorFlow
that you've seen before
and that people use it?
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
So Keras gets referenced a
lot because it's a great way
to engage with TensorFlow or
with other neural net platforms
that exist out there.
It's nice, higher-level abstract
to engage with that space.
So Keras is great.
You can definitely use that
on Google Cloud Platform.
You just to configure the actual
servers to be able to use it.
There are other libraries
that are constantly
being referenced, like
PyTorch and Caffe.
There's definitely
a few others that
are out there that I
would recommend exploring
because each one has
its own value in terms
of how it's being applied.
MARK MANDEL: So I know
with Cloud ML Engine,
the TensorFlow setup can be--
the calculations
can be distributed
across multiple computers.
If you're coming
to GCP and using
something else like PyTorch
or something like that,
do those come with tools that
also will enable you to set up
a multitude of computers so you
can distribute that workload?
Or how does that
kind of thing work?
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
And I know we were talking
about this earlier.
So I wrote a blog
post about this
recently because I wanted to
make sure it is clear to people
that TensorFlow
is very valuable,
and I recommend
people exploring that.
But if you are already
using something
and you want to be able to
use Google Cloud Platform,
I think is important to
understand that whatever you're
using you can bring over.
So I wrote this
post in particular
to show you have to spend some
time doing the configuration.
If you already have an install
script or some type of docker
image that you use to
configure your instances,
then you can use that.
You don't have to spend the
time doing the configuration.
You just kick off whatever you
need using Kubernetes, using
whatever it is that will
help get those servers up
and running for you.
You just have to have some way
of doing the configuration,
and then you can bring
over your software.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So when using
that software, as soon as Mark
said big scale and
the cloud and stuff,
I started thinking
about big data.
And I'm curious about the
relationship between big data
and things like Spark
and [? MapThus ?]
and stuff like that and
what we talk about machine
learning and AI.
Is AI part of big data?
Is big data part of AI?
What are the
relationships there?
MELANIE WARRICK:
The relationship
between big data and AI is that,
in some of these algorithms
and many of the algorithms,
the data will actually
help build them and
make them successful
and make them actually work
well, especially when you
get to neural nets.
So big data is about
having the data
you need to train the model,
and that's what it's all about.
I mean, frankly,
most of the work
you do when you're
building these models is
getting the data and having the
data cleaned and ready to go.
Something I like to
tell people all the time
is never trust the data.
Data needs to be fully vetted
and cleaned and processed,
and like 80% of your time
can be spent on that.
But you do have to spend
the time figuring out
what it is you
have, what you need,
and getting it into a format and
into some type of data platform
that will serve it
to your models--
for training, for inference,
for whatever it is
you're going to do.
Well, the tools we
have for big data,
we just have to be to plug
that into the software
and the servers
that you're using.
MARK MANDEL: So now
I'm also curious,
I think you alluded
earlier, that sort
of the whole aspect
of AI is around sort
of continual learning
and the platform
learning from itself
as it goes forward.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
MARK MANDEL: What
does that look like?
Are you just redoing the same
training over and over again,
or is that a slightly
different process as it grows?
How does that work?
MELANIE WARRICK: It can vary.
When you're using some
type of algorithm,
like a Markov algorithm
where the statistics that
are involved in it will
continually sort of adapt based
on real-time readings of
reactions from people,
that would be one way where the
algorithm itself is adapting
as the reactions are coming in
and it's reading it real time.
Sometimes you do have to do
training offline, or many times
you have to do
training offline, where
you will pick frequency
of how often you do it
with the new data
that you've captured.
So it can take a couple
of different forms
in terms of real
time versus offline.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
following on the same topic,
since you have algorithms
that continuously adapt
to the conditions and to
the contexts where they're
executing, does
that mean that you
should be worried about the
algorithms learning something
wrong?
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: By that,
I mean, for instance, you
have a self-driving car that
learns how to drive by itself.
How do you make
sure that it doesn't
learn how to drive
backwards on the highway?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Human in the mix.
You've got to have some
levels of humans evaluating
the system, as well
as you definitely need
to put in safeguards.
And yes, this is why I
say never trust the data.
You also don't fully
trust the models.
You have to constantly be
testing and evaluating.
We've seen examples
of products that
are out there that didn't really
work the way they expected.
I think, frankly,
as an engineer,
you learn really quickly--
you want to believe you can
write this code that you don't
need to fully
test, but all of it
needs to be tested constantly.
And you have to constantly
be thinking about what
it is you might be missing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
How do you test it?
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, it
depends on what you're doing.
Sometimes you test
it by writing tests.
Sometimes you test it by
exposing it to small samples.
Sometimes you put
it into the wild,
and then you find out really
quickly that maybe you
shouldn't have and
you pull back and then
you hope for better results
the next time you do it.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
I've definitely heard
that, in people's minds,
people think, oh, I'm going to
sprinkle AI or ML over a thing
and it's just going to give
me this perfect result.
But it seems like the AI or
the ML might get you 80% there.
And then from there, it's
sort of nudging and scraping
and crafting until you
get a good product.
MELANIE WARRICK: Something
I like to stress of people.
You know, it's true with
anything with modeling,
when you're doing anything
with machine learning,
you have to come up
with the right question
or the right problem
you're solving for
before you pick any tools,
before you do anything.
Then you start to
have to think about,
what is the data that
I have to do this?
And it doesn't have to
be big data all the time.
People can do
artificial intelligence
with small samples.
There's research on that.
But you have to
think about the data.
What's the current
setup of the data?
And then you can
start to do the model.
It takes time to
actually develop anything
and to really see,
is it effective?
And you have to also
ask yourself, what is it
you're trying to achieve for?
We're typically
evaluating and saying--
accuracy is the easiest
thing to explain.
There's a number of ways
to evaluate these metrics,
but you have to ask yourself at
what percentage is acceptable?
If it's something
that's life or death,
maybe I need to be
99.9999% accurate on this.
If it's something that is
like, we're playing a game
and it needs to win
most of the time,
maybe 80% to 90%
accuracy is acceptable.
MARK MANDEL: This is
where I ask questions
based on very vague knowledge.
I believe you can
sort of overtrain
if you have certain data sets.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Can you
explain what that is
and how to beat that or
hopefully that doesn't happen?
Is there a magic
wand or something?
MELANIE WARRICK: You guys are
asking all the good questions.
Like, tell us exactly.
And it's interesting,
too, trying
to do this verbally
versus actually having--
I usually love showing images
because it sometimes helps
kind of hit the point home.
But yes, you can
definitely overfit,
and you can also underfit.
So when you overfit,
it means you've
made it so that the perfectly
fits the training data set
that it's been exposed to.
But it doesn't generalize.
If you show it anything new
that it hasn't seen before,
then it won't be able to
give any kind of prediction
or classification that
is actually useful
because it's become so
perfectly fit to the data.
When you look at drawing a
line for linear regression
to a data set, that's
a great example.
If you look up what
overfitting looks like for just
linear regression, I think you
can get a good visual sense
of what that looks like.
And so people put what's
known as regularization
into your models.
It makes it kind of fuzzy.
It makes it a
little more general.
And regularization
is extremely key
when you're doing deep learning
and anything with neural nets
because that's an area
that easily overfits.
So you don't want it to
be too perfectly matched
to the training
set, and you always
want to set aside some
data it's never seen before
to see when you're testing it.
Does it work and apply?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I heard an example that I
thought it was really cool.
I think it was when we did
the episode with Kaggle.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: A very
good example of overfitting
was you tried to predict
the price of houses.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And one of the
houses is let's say $2 million
and has one broken door.
And you could learn that
whenever any house has
a broken door, it should be a
$3 million no matter how big it
is.
Specific things like, oh
yeah, that's totally wrong.
So yeah, I really like that.
It's very interesting.
MELANIE WARRICK: I don't know
the exact details of this,
but I had this example
explained to me once
where, way back in the
day when they were first
exploring neural nets,
they did this training on I
think it was tanks.
And they were trying to get
recognizing between the US
and Russian tanks.
But the problem is they
trained the actual algorithm
with all these US
tanks that were
taken by really well-done
marketing shots in really
sunny spaces, whereas
the Russian tanks were
are cloudy and
difficult and grainy.
When they tried it
out in the real world,
they had it thinking
everything was a tank
because it was grainy and dark.
And it had basically
trained on the clouds
and on the sunshine versus
the actual tank itself.
So anyways, yes,
it's funny when you
start to dig into
these algorithms
to see what specifically is it
really focusing on as the way
to say this is my way
to classify or predict.
And it's very common
that people resist
using deep learning in
particular because of that
because it's hard
to fully break into.
And they're working on this.
It's called interpretability.
But they're working
on understanding
why is the algorithm picking
the classification that it is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is
actually super interesting,
and I thought that that
was not a thing at all.
Once you have a neural network,
if you have something that
predicts numbers, somehow
you can see some layers
inside of a neural network
kind of showing, well,
this recognizes a circle.
So you kind of figure out.
Is that a thing at higher
scale, like if you're trying
to recognize, is this a cat?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Can you actually
see that in the neural network?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
They've got some great
examples out there
in terms of showing what
are these nets really seeing
when it looks for the cat.
What are some of
the distinct, what's
known as features, to
help identify the data
set in particular?
And there's great images
out there actually
online that will give you a
perspective on how it focuses.
Classifying a 7 versus a 9,
it will look at that loop
that the nine will have
that the 7 won't have,
and that will be
the feature that
helps it distinguish
between the two numbers
and creates a
higher probability.
MARK MANDEL: So how does it
do that given a neural net
is essentially it's math, right?
So how can you determine
from these numbers
that there's a loop?
It's looking at the loop?
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, yeah.
Now you want me to
explain the math verbally.
This is awesome.
I mean, the way
it's doing it, it's
basically converting the image.
So in images in
particular, it converts it
all into numerical values.
And then, based on the
way you do the math,
it will find a way to
emphasize specifically
the numerical values for
that part of the image.
So the image itself
gets converted
into numerical values.
There's a lot of
math that's going on.
And within that, it's
emphasizing and saying,
focus on this specific area.
If you see this area in
terms of numerical values--
let's say it's all
grayscale, and 1s and 0s--
I'll just make it
really simple--
are focused in the specific
area of the picture.
Then if you see
that, then that's
a high probability
it's going to be a 9.
So that certain ways.
And how you actually see
that in the image itself
or how you see that
in the neural net
is ways that we take the actual
data set inside of the net
and visualize it.
I'm going to say that's my
best way of explaining that,
frankly, right now,
but you find ways
to surface it and
visualize and convert
what the actual model looks
like into some type of--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I see
that as almost like debugging
a program, where you're actually
see the value of the variables
when you're executing.
You can kind of
see, oh, these are
the pieces that are activating
because [? it sees ?] around
or whatever.
Does that mean
that, whenever you
train a big neural network that
is able to recognize circles
and lines and
whatever, you could
reuse that part to then
train on something else.
Like, for instance,
let's say no, you're
going to try to
recognize diagrams
or something like that.
MELANIE WARRICK: So you are
bringing up transfer learning,
and that's become a
really popular thing.
A couple of things I'll say
about this around neural nets
in particular.
Neural nets came to popularity
recently in the last few years
because the computation
power was there
to actually do these
computations you have to do,
the intensive computation
you have to do for it,
and the data was available.
What was initially popular
for neural nets was feature
engineering, feature
engineering meaning
that you can run data
through it and you
identify the primary important
parts of the data that
will help you build the model.
And that's something that
people had to do manually,
and it was really
intensive for a long time.
But using a neural net
made it a lot easier.
Now, people are getting
excited about what's known
as transfer learning, where--
more so with neural nets--
because you've already
got trained models that
have been successful,
and they're good at some
type of image classification.
And you can take
parts of that model
and apply it to a different
image classification problem,
and it's quick to train, quick
to apply, quick to adapt.
So it's cool.
It's like figuring
out a cat and a dog,
and it gets used for figuring
out trees or something.
MARK MANDEL: That's
very human in that way.
Like I've done sport X, and
I used to do like one thing,
and then I can do
exactly the same thing.
You took basketball
skills, took it over
to something like netball
or something like that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That's
kind of super cool.
So when is the robot
uprising, and when should I
expect the robot overlords?
MELANIE WARRICK: Tomorrow.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's already here.
You just didn't know
that they were already
telling you all the things.
MARK MANDEL: I'm OK with this.
I just thought I'd ask.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I will say this.
There was some
research done around
the superintelligence
space and all the people
who were predicting
when we were going
to have superintelligence.
And they averaged
out the time frame,
and the expectation is 2040.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 2040?
Oh, wow.
MARK MANDEL: That's soon,
sooner than I thought.
MELANIE WARRICK:
But you've got time.
MARK MANDEL: I've got time.
MELANIE WARRICK: You've
got plenty of time
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So there was
there was this clash of titans.
There was Mark
Zuckerberg and Elon Musk
publicly discussing AI.
And basically, one is saying
AI is super dangerous,
we should be super
careful with it.
The other one was like,
no, AI will save the world.
What is your bent on this?
What is your opinion?
Will AI destroy
or save the world?
MARK MANDEL: And it can
only be one or the other.
There's no in between.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I plead the fifth.
So I've seen this argument
playing out, especially
in the last couple of years.
I think that the fear
is used to get people
to do things or
to, I don't know,
react in ways that
is not necessarily
as beneficial, frankly.
I'm not a fan of doing a lot
of, let's be afraid, let's
be really afraid.
But I do think you
need to be careful.
And I know a lot
of the researchers
are trying to advocate
for some of the challenges
that they see coming
and trying to advocate
responsibly for ways we can come
up against those challenges.
I know this isn't as
much fun as, yeah, they
should throw down
and fight it out,
and this is the best
person in there.
I do see there's a lot
of hype in this space.
There's a lot of hype, and
it is concerning in some ways
because I think people
can get caught up in it
and make poor decisions
and buy into things
that are not going to be useful
for them in the long run.
But, unlike the
past with AI, where
we saw hype in the '50s and
then this AI winter and hype
again in like the '80s and
'90s and again a dropout,
we are seeing real applications,
like identifying cancer cells
in images, that are beneficial,
so beneficial to us.
And so this isn't completely
overhyped in terms of there's
not some real value there.
It's just you have to be careful
about the hype and the fear
and be realistic about
what is it being used for,
where is it useful, and
then see what you need to do
to be responsible about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
mentioned that researchers
were being very careful
about some concerns they had.
Can you give an example
of one of those concerns?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Some of the concerns
I've heard more recently,
and I think most people are
talking about this, is jobs.
Are we going to have
automated away all the jobs?
I don't know.
There's conversations around,
do we automate them all away
or do we just make new jobs?
And so I'm not
enough of an expert
to be able to completely weigh
in on will this really happen.
And I think most of the
researchers don't fully know,
but there are some
conversations and discussion
of what does that look like.
Some other concerns are along
what you were talking about
before, with testing,
and how do we
know we're putting stuff
out into the wild that
is not going to harm people?
And make sure we
have the right level.
And I say harm.
I'm not talking about them
killing everybody off,
but I am saying having the
right safeguards in place.
So they're not completely off
base those who talk about this,
and I know [? Yomas ?] is
one of those, where they're
trying to say, do we
have the right safeguards
to make sure that AI is going
to be impactful in useful ways?
MARK MANDEL: And like what you
were talking about, making sure
that a human stays in the mix.
It's great if you
have a computer saying
these are cancer cells
or these are not,
but having a doctor
alongside saying, actually,
let's double check that
and we'll take an action
and I'll take that
information as a suggestion
or part of the packet of
overall everything I'm doing.
I think it's quite interesting.
I've heard things of
chess leagues and stuff
where they allow like human
and computer AI interactions
as teams being able
to work together.
And I think going forward,
you could see that
as being the thing that happens.
It's never just
one or the other.
It's both together.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
MARK MANDEL: We are running
out of time, unfortunately.
I'm having a great conversation.
Before we finish
up, though, is there
anything you want to make sure
you plug, any events you're
going to, maybe something you're
super excited that you just
want to make sure gets on the
podcast before we finish up?
MELANIE WARRICK:
I'm looking forward
to speaking on the AI panel
at Grace Hopper in Orlando.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: So that's
coming up in October,
and I definitely
want to mention that.
But yeah, I've got a number
of talks that are coming up,
I like Strada and
O'Reilly's AI conference.
So thanks.
Thanks for letting me plug.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll
have all of those
on the show notes in case anyone
wants to go find you and ask
you about robot uprising.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Definitely
have an opinion then.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
This was amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks
so much to Melanie
for sharing her opinions
on AI and machine learning
and what are the
differences and also
what's going to
happen in the future.
Are we going to have to welcome
our machine-learned overlords?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I welcome them totally.
I want to be clear on that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Me too.
I love them.
OK.
I guess it's time to go.
Our question of the week
is about Kubernetes.
So in Kubernetes, you have pods.
And those pods,
whenever they die--
they are actually pretty
short-lived sometimes--
and whenever one dies, if
you have a service that says,
well, I should have let's
say 10 instances of it,
a new one is created.
And you don't really
have control on that.
Whenever a pod dies,
a new one is created.
Now, how would you do something
in between those actions?
Meaning like, if I want to
do something at the moment
a new pod is created,
how do we do that?
And if I want to do
something the moment
a pod is killed or is
detected or considered
to be dead, how do you do that?
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So this is actually
something that
gets me kind of very
excited about Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes has a
whole REST API as well as
a series of clients for most
languages, like Go and Python
and other ones as well.
And what makes me get
excited about Kubernetes
is that Kubernetes is
this amazing thing that
does a lot of really cool
work in terms of deployments
and services and
stuff like that,
but it also gives you so
much of the building blocks
and the APIs to
make it do all sorts
of other interesting
stuff programmatically
so you can really control it.
So one of those
things that it has
is basically a whole watch API.
Most of the clients
wrap that up.
You can access it also directly
through the REST API as well.
You can basically say, hey, tell
me whenever this stuff happens.
So for example, what
we're talking about here,
hey, tell me whenever an
event happens for a pod.
And you can actually apply
filters to those as well,
and you can do fun
stuff like that.
And what's cool about
that then is then
I can just have maybe a
deployment that happens.
It sits on Kubernetes.
It can connect to the Kubernetes
API through the client.
And it can say, hey,
tell me whenever
something happens with a pod.
And so when one gets created,
it will get a message
saying something happened.
When one gets deleted, it gets
a message, something happened.
And then programmatically, you
could either tell Kubernetes
to do something else, maybe
fire off a message to a log,
do some analytics or
some sort of metrics.
There's all sorts of fun stuff
you could definitely do here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So does that
mean that you do a request
and you give some
kind of callback
that it will be
called, like a webhook?
Or is it like a long thing
and you just get new messages
from that connection?
MARK MANDEL: So it depends on
your client and how it does it.
So I usually use the Go client.
So what it normally does is
it hands you back a channel,
and then data gets
pushed into that channel.
If people aren't
familiar with channels,
think of it basically as
like a blocking queue.
And then data goes into that,
and then I can just pick up
that as it comes through.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: And then I can do
a Go routine, so basically fork
off another thread and
keep on running from there.
And it's really
straightforward, and I
don't have to worry about
starting processes or killing
processes or tracking
any of that stuff.
Kubernetes handles all that
for me, which is lovely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
My favorite thing is actually
not only the fact of this API
exists, but that this API
is also used by [? Cube ?]
[? QTL, ?] also known
as [? Cube ?] [? CTL, ?]
but [? Cube ?]
[? QTL ?] in my house.
And it's something that
not that many people know,
but you can do things like--